[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qui sinon ça va être h et on s'aime
beaucoup tous les deux ma vie c'est une
star d'amour depuis très longtemps je
sais chaque fois ravi d'être là aussi
toujours la bienvenue
j'ai déjà plus il est content d'être
venu si dans quand on s'aime je vous
demandais quelque chose je vais faire
défiler les chroniqueurs a par après il
y aura le grand combat du défilé entre
matthieu delormeau et camille combal
mais vous avez vous dire vraiment ce
qu'ils doivent changer si son magnifique
coupable ni failli vous dit vraiment la
vérité
[Applaudissements]
quoi
[Musique]
dites nous la vérité alors jean-luc le
boîte ça c'est le style est ce qui se
fait dans les jours le diacre à ouidah
mauvais pas mauvais par mauvais pas
mauvais et coûte le kaki c'est très bien
ça va bien je pense que tu as bien
dessinés et en attirant sur deux je
pense comme maje mettrait en jeu m haies
en 7
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la série suit là alors on va assumer qui
est extravagante des fidèles à toi même
je te donne un set partout
[Applaudissements]
à mon avis on va descendre tous les
moyens
forte moi je trouve que bonds a de toute
façon la leçon dont les classiques à
jean chemise blanche avait ce noir
chaussures bien cirées
mais il manque un peu de jeu ces
difficultés touchent peut-être un peu
trop tard août nous calmons nous
tueraient n'est pas très moderne
j'aurais fait un affranchissement niveau
coiffure ouais voyez le jean est bonne
et un peu plus un peu mais qui peut-être
un peu tous brut nom qui nous auraient
permis à vous donner
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
attention on va passer à la deuxième
épreuve fashion en toute circonstance du
premier passage ce week-end à mac
[Applaudissements]
il
partie de chasse c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les résultats ses portes les emmerdes
[Applaudissements]
oh
non
[Musique]